I'm sitting in our brand-new studio
space and I know that excites a lot of
you because you've been clamoring for us
to get back in studio and record our in
studio episodes the feedback we've
gotten is you love the live podcast but
you love the in studio themed episodes
even more so starting next week we are
back in studio full-time looking forward
to sharing some of those episodes with
you until then we have one final live
episode and it was certainly one of my
favorites what you're about to hear is
our final live episodes I actually was
the final stop of the 2017 lesses now
tour was Milwaukee with our good friend
Colin Wright with us
everything was firing on all cylinders
and made me want to go back and redo the
entire tour to see if we can get it
right the same way that we had in
Milwaukee if you do want to see us live
we have a couple events before we're
done touring for a while we're gonna be
in Australia and New Zealand in March
we've got seven cities over there Perth
and Adelaide and Melbourne and Brisbane
and Sydney and Oakland a few of those
are already sold out but there are
tickets left two to several of them
still and then also we're filming a new
documentary it's called the minimalists
less is now and we're building this
documentary around the talk that we've
given over the course of the last year
and we wanted to film that talk in a
really beautiful space so we rented out
this beautiful warehouse in Los Angeles
and we're inviting 600 of you we're
doing two events a 3 p.m. event and a 7
p.m. event on February 10th and you're
welcome to join us for that live event
the 3 p.m. event is already sold out
there's still a few tickets left for the
7 p.m. event if you want to be part of
this documentary if you want to be part
of this talk if you want to see us live
you can find us there February 10th or
in March we'll be in Australia and New
Zealand all the information is on our
website just head on over to the
minimalists comm slash tour you can find
all the dates and ticket information
over there alright so we're back in
studio next week and you're gonna love
the space it looks beautiful so make
sure you're on our email list if you're
not already you'll see some photos and
and all we're gonna add a video
component to the podcast soon as well
once we get enough patreon supporters so
we're steamrolling closer and closer to
that in the meantime I really hope you
enjoy this live version of the
minimalist podcast in Milwaukee
[Music]
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed oh I bet that you'll
be fine without him live from Turner
hall my name is Josh from filth Wilburn
and I am Ryan Nicodemus and together we
are the minimalists live in Milwaukee
all right it's nice we love you more you
know we're doing 50 cities this year and
this is the end of our North American
tour and our booking agent said where's
a great place for us to go in the winter
to finish this thing and he was like how
about Milwaukee I'm like hell yeah and
and now we're here and and we have an
appropriate guest for tonight because
this journey started for us as you know
we started the web site about seven
years ago actually be seven years ago
next week it's crazy
and so maybe eight eight and a half
years ago I stumbled across this thing
called minimalism thanks to this guy so
because of the guy were about to bring
out on stage he's sort of the reason
that we're all congregated here tonight
he is an author of 33 books I believe
now at age 32 and why do we invite him
to be on stage with us again to outshine
us well because I like being embarrassed
in front of hundreds of people
he has a great podcast called let's know
things he is a world traveler a
minimalist and one of my closest friends
in the world ladies and gentlemen Colin
right
[Applause]
it's it's a hell of a book in you know
seven years have have gone by since we
we started the website is it weird that
I feel like we kind of still just
started no it's not weird at all we were
just backstage talking about this so our
very first tour was six years ago and
the fourth stop we were in Knoxville and
no one showed up and and as we were
leave I were waiting and waiting as we
were leaving two people walked in and
hey you're the minimalists damn right we
are
and we sort of just had a one-on-one
session for an hour with two people and
there there's something appealing about
that and and now we're really fortunate
that you all are willing to show up and
even pay it again that's really amazing
so thank you for being here and Collin
thank you for being here it's been a
hell of a journey for us
I know minimalism isn't your main gig
like it is ours but you started a
podcast recently and and the thing that
I and we we give you [ __ ] about it all
the time because Colin is literally one
of the smartest people I know but he's
also the thing that that is more
intriguing than just the fact that he's
smartest he's really curious and so the
title of your podcast lets know things
it started just because you're like I
want to learn some stuff and I'd like to
instead of just learning it myself
selfishly I want to share it with people
can you talk about that a little bit
yeah it's interesting because we talked
a whole lot about minimalism and that
that's kind of a the journey that gets
you where you want to go but for each
and every one of us I think there's
something that we want to get to there's
a reason that you're trying to clear
away stuff the in essential stuff and
it's like minimalism is not the
destination exactly yeah and of course
life is a continuous journey so that
you're going to continue to iterate but
there's something probably that you have
in mind that you're realizing that
you're not able to do now and for me it
was kind of like being able to sit and
read a book all day and like never see
anyone and just sit there glued to the
book and read about really obscure stuff
that nobody else
cares about and then try to put it into
a format in which I can make other
people care about it and share these
things that I think are so interesting
in a compelling way and so the podcast
really is about that at the end of the
day it's communicating things that I
think are important that we don't have a
whole lot of vehicles for delivering to
people right now the mediums that we
have set up on the internet and
elsewhere are not primed for this type
of thing and and for me what allowed me
to do it is clearing out all that other
stuff because frankly it takes a whole
lot of time to sit and indulge in all of
this reading and and being isolated from
society as I do it well in any
introverts out there and and the
interesting thing is like the the topics
they they span I mean such a wide
variety of and you on one episode you
might be talking about genealogy and and
artificial intelligence and then then
the following week you're talking about
sex dolls and and it it's it's a
constant journey of sort of exploring
you know this almost sounds cliche but
like like the hidden side of we all you
go beyond the Wikipedia page in a way
I'm glad you think that yeah that's the
aim they in the aim to like this is this
is the interesting thing that
unfortunately it's it's another thing
that's difficult to convey using
traditional modes of communication that
everything is connected there's not
really any delineation between different
fields of study and if you look close
enough and deeper and deeper you can see
that root structure and so trying to
connect these diverse subsets of life of
research of industry of everything else
and break down the silos that to me is a
very compelling story to tell and if you
go back and listen to all the episodes
all of them kind of connect in a way to
despite the the seeming disconnect
between things like AI and sex dolls
there's a deep connection there no pun
intended
[Laughter]
I'm very sorry now now is it is it true
that you record every episode in a
loincloth as I often forget the
loincloth
ladies and gentlemen minimalism hashtag
minimalism how about we answer some
questions y'all
howdy what's your name hi I'm Carrie I'm
from Peoria Illinois
I teach back home and in the spring I
have this really cool opportunity to do
a week-long class on basically whatever
I want so I've chosen to do week-long
class on minimalism and I have a lot of
high schoolers who are actually really
really excited for this class and my
question for you is what would you say
to a group of high schoolers what advice
would you give or direction would you
give them about ms about minimalism as
they're just a few years out from
stepping out into the world and managing
their own lives yeah well right now
there are few years out potentially from
stepping into a lifelong commitment of
debt and that that is terrifying and and
I like to I mean much like your podcast
it's its exploration through questioning
quite often and and right now what I
would encourage anyone to do but
especially people who are in high school
I mean it's it's the weirdest thing in
the world we say alright you're 18 now
here's six figures worth of debt go
figure it out we wouldn't do that for
any anything else besides schooling we
wouldn't say you know what Ryan you're
18 now here's a hundred and fifty
thousand dollars go start a business
with it
although or go start ten businesses ten
fifteen thousand dollar businesses with
it we don't do that but we we often get
saddled with that and we don't know the
direction in which we want to travel
right and so I'm not gonna sit up here
and say that I think all schooling is
inherently evil it's not I think there's
certainly a purpose for it but the
question is are you following someone
else's path or are you following the
path that you that you want to follow
and then the question is why is that you
path right for me when I turned 18
Ryan told the store the story earlier of
life well if we could just make X amount
of dollars then I'll be happy right and
the path for that was like well then
I'll go get the sales job right and I'll
start climbing this corporate ladder I
never asked why and five years down the
road I had climbed high enough that I
was like scared to jump down I was
scared to change course because it
wasn't meant backtracking and now is a
great time they don't have to backtrack
they can figure out what that course is
going to be yeah I think first off like
when high school kids show up at our
events like it is one of the biggest
compliments ever I'm also a little
jealous cuz like I thought I was like
ahead of the game at 28 and then when
someone you know like 15 or 16 shows up
I'm like god there's so much more
further ahead than me yeah of course I'm
happy for him but wish I would have
started a little younger so to a high
school kid though who has never heard of
us though and you know you're trying to
introduce them to to the minimalists I
think in high school I had this idea of
what successful was and it was shaped
very much by advertisements it was
shaped by the things that my friends had
the the houses that I worked in when I
was working for my dad the house is that
my other friends lived in whatever
influences that I had in my life it was
always about comparing myself to others
success and then I could tell whether or
not I was successful and I think with
high school kids the one thing I would
really try and help them understand is
that there is no one definition for
success and to add to that I would say
if you're trying to be successful by by
having more money or more things there
is no one there's no there's no role
model that on their deathbed is like man
thank God I bought all those things
thank God I spend all that money and
ignored all those important things in my
life for stuff no one ever done now you
do have some reality TV stars and
musicians and other things that will
show an ostensible life that looks
amazing but you know it's I mean I'm not
gonna sit and call it any I really want
to but I'm not gonna call it any
particular star but we know the stories
of everything's great and then no it's
actually not great and we see that way
more often than then the obverse of that
so I would really try to help kids
understand that success is not what
their friends do and measuring success
off of money and things is is it's not
the it's not the best route mm-hmm great
points I would also tell them that to
start rather than starting by just going
through and getting rid of a bunch of
stuff willy-nilly it's easy to get
caught up in the ritual and the rituals
by themself like going through the
habits and routines and walking those
paces that can be valuable unto itself
but it's even more valuable I would
argue if before you start doing it you
take a great big step backwards and take
a look at the big picture look at your
life look at what you hope to accomplish
look at where you want to go even if
there's nothing specific no specific
career trajectory or passion that you
want to pursue even if it's just freeing
up time to figure out what your passion
is having an idea of that first allows
you to be a whole lot more particular
and a whole lot more efficient in terms
of what you reduce in terms of the
habits that you add into your routine as
you reduce the number of negative habits
that are not adding anything to your
life so taking that step backwards first
looking at the big picture identifying
which general direction you want to go
and then allowing that to guide what
ritual or exercises you take on after
that Kari thank you for doing what you
do and thank you for making the right up
from Peoria really appreciate ya and I
know there are other teachers in this
audience and I want to thank all of you
as well
thank you thank you howdy what's your
name where you from hi I'm Andrea I live
just outside Milwaukee and I'm so
excited you guys are here thank you for
being here thanks for making this the
last part of your winter trip you know
what we almost didn't make it here today
we spent about eight hours at the
Detroit Airport today and they delayed
the flight then they delayed it again
then they led us on the flight and then
the pilot was late and then after the
pilot showed up that I all right this is
gonna take 45 minutes at the ice the
plane and they D ice to play and they
started taxing away and they say hey I
[ __ ] you not he comes on the overhead
the intercom he said our check engine
light just came on big fans in Detroit
they'll say anything to keep these guys
there and and so late he's like we're
gonna return to the gate and we get back
to the gate and we walked the we we're
just waiting there we're not sure if
we're gonna let you off the plane and
eventually okay we're gonna deep plane
now and I'm like well I contact our book
age I'm like I don't think I don't think
Milwaukee's gonna happen tonight wasn't
into the tour and last minute they're
like right we've rebooked the plane and
we're putting gas in it and like we
literally went right from the airport
straight to here and we made it here
tonight so thank you for being here so
happy to be here
we're very happy that you're here as
well so my question I'm curious about
your typical day week month and what
makes now the happy life that you've
dreamed of and that you've created for
yourselves what does that mean to you
now and what does that look like so I my
life is measurably happier than than
what it was for sure I think the biggest
reason why it is happier is because I'm
no longer chasing happiness and instead
I'm I'm living a meaningful life and
what that means for me is aligning my
daily actions with what my values are
and that also means course-correcting
from time to time
I just wrote an essay recently about my
need to say no like I accidentally
became busy this year and and for me
busy is the worst vulgar word in all of
the the English language it's the worst
four-letter word there is and and and I
accidentally like allowed these I said
yes to a lot of things that individually
we're actually good things to say yes to
it wasn't nonsense it wasn't like well
yeah I'm gonna say yes to scrolling
through Facebook for seven hours today
it was saying yes to all all of these
things that independently were all
really good things to say yes to but
when you stack them on top of each other
it's a a couple years ago the United
Nations released their list of 163
priorities
now let me explain something to you the
the word priority was not a plural until
the 20th century and so priority
literally means the first thing the
United Nations has a hundred and
sixty-three first things it's like last
a couple weeks ago the Black Friday and
then there's Cyber Monday and now I'm
seeing all these businesses Cyber Monday
week and it just becomes nonsense and
what I realized this year is like oh
[ __ ] I've developed a lot of priorities
and my priorities started getting in the
way of my priorities and and then I
realized I had to step back and I had to
say no because it literally made me sick
and and three weeks ago was the first
time we've ever had to cancel a show in
in seven years we were in Washington DC
and I realized like wow I've taken on
too much and I need to step back and I
need to reprioritize
and so a day in my life
actually here's if I had something that
was shorter this Jimmy this thing Jimmy
Kimmel said he said I'm paraphrasing
here but if it's on my calendar I don't
enjoy it and I'm sure that resonates
with some of you right and so I try to
put very few things on my calendar and
I'm happier when when there's less when
fewer things are scheduled yeah I don't
have any particular routine especially
with the crazy tour schedule I mean this
year at the beginning of the year it
started with we were going to film a
special for Netflix which we have an
awesome relationship with they're
awesome over there and then Andrew
Russell kind of threw a wrench in
everything he's our booking agent and he
like head to something he's like you
guys should go on tour right now and I
would love to represent you and this is
like the first legit tour we have ever
been on so up until this year
we Josh and I have been responsible for
booking venues showing up and setting up
the venue sound lights everything
unfolding the chairs
oh I learn in London England in 2014 I
learned that I should bring an extra
t-shirt with me because chances are I'm
gonna be really sweaty right before I
get on stage
that also means borrowing couches by the
way I've toured with these guys before
borrowing couches borrowing beds and
sometimes it's the three of us on a
futon and josh is a cuddler
Colin it was your idea dude you try to
roll away he comes after you so so this
year you know it's been really hectic
and I have not had like one particular
like here's my 8 hour schedule which I
kind of like I kind of like mixing it up
but I will say that I focus on three
things every single day I focus on
exercise like somehow I've got to get
some push-ups in I'm talking like bare
minimum I've got to do something most
days Mariah and I are at the gym and we
hit it hard we hit it hard every single
day we know I was trying not I was
trying to make a joke and I really just
sounded like it more of a bro guy there
like I didn't mean to but but no but I
focus on exercise I focus on adding
value to my relationship so if it's not
Mariah than it's jos if it's not josh
then it's my mom if it's not my mom then
it's it's Colin or maybe it's maybe I'll
hit them all up in one day I don't but I
am always asking myself like who Evan I
talked to who who do I feel like I
really need to give some attention due
today and how can I show the people
around me that I love them and
appreciate them the third thing is is I
will take at least if it's not you know
five minutes it'll be a minute of
meditation and and I will take a second
to to try to reset myself a little bit
other than that
the biggest thing for me is making sure
that all of my my short-term actions are
in alignment with my my long-term values
and beliefs so that's really where I'm
focused on so if I was to say like what
is my routine like that's really my
routine is everyday I'm focused on
making the best decisions possible so I
can thank my my 37 year old self my 40
year old self so I can really feel good
about what I've done with my time and
resources but but yeah it's it's not a
typical routine it's just focusing for
me on those core values and and really
really hitting those hard now Colin you
have your life has changed a little bit
recently intentionally when I first met
you is 2009 and at the time and up until
very recently you were traveling to a
new country every four months and I
really admired that but everything that
he owned fit into his like bag and that
was all he owned and I'm like wait a
minute in order to become a minimalist
you have to own 52 items no more than
that or you don't get your minimalist
card which is one of your items 51 items
and and so I'm I I'm I admire him for
what he was doing but not because of the
travel I hate travel and but I I
realized that like he was pursuing when
he was passionate about the weird thing
was though he was traveling to a new
country over four months and he didn't
pick the country the people on his
website his blog is called exile
lifestyle by the way so it's great blog
he's the best nonfiction writer on the
internet and I mean that sincerely and
when you take me out of the picture and
I was waiting for it and it was it was
really fascinating because like I was
just talking to Josh Rebecca about this
recently and he was saying you know I
saw this I'm like you ever think about
doing that with your family just letting
other people pick where you move every
four months and you ended up in some
like really unique place you wouldn't
think about because people were voting
on where to go so you're in India one
month and then four months later you're
in Iceland and then and then you are and
you're Argentina or wherever you're all
over the world and then recently you
said you know what like I want to like I
want to figure out like how how to sort
of react la make myself into the states
and so you ended up in the booming
metropolis of Wichita Kansas yeah yeah a
few tons not super surprised and and
then and then recently people voted on
what state you were gonna go to and it
was Tennessee and so you are currently
living in Memphis Tennessee and so Wow
and and you are you're at this point in
your life where you're no longer like
just being the Peripatetic writer and
you may go back to doing that but you
actually have rituals for the first time
in a long time
it's very strange yeah and this is how
this connects to that question I go
since 2009 so since I was 24 I'm 32 now
I have had to develop habits that are
portable and modular things that can be
moved around and done from anywhere
depending
Arlis of the infrastructure available I
couldn't carry weights with me I could
that would be stupid
if you use all carry-on luggage do not
carry weights even kettlebells are sexy
I know do not put one in your luggage
it's not worth it
and be hauling that around a whole lot
get more than you bargained for but
everything has to be modular and
reformat a bowl depending on your
circumstances and in some places people
wake up super early in some places
there's going to be like the call to
prayer at a certain time of day and in
some places it's going to move a lot
more slowly there's going to be
electricity all day in some places not
so much didn't they make you drink vodka
like for breakfast or something and
hungry yeah yeah in some places you're
drunk all day not by your own design
because of somebody's grandmother
feeding it to you for breakfast and so
you really have to be able to roll with
the punches so for most of my 20s onward
that's how my rituals have been so I've
I kind of broke my rituals and habits up
into chunks that I could do it about 20
minutes at a time and so something that
I've continued to do since 2009 is I
take 20 minutes a day to sit quietly and
do nothing and no music no mantras no
humming no not not even like breathing
exercises or anything I've tried a bunch
of different types of meditation and
they're all valuable in their own way I
think to different people for me what I
find works really well is sitting
staring at nothing letting my vision
blur a little bit and just allowing my
mind to unspool and just do what it's
going to do and worry about stuff and
get to the bottom of it come to
solutions or not there's no goal except
to take that quiet time and allow my
brain to do what its gonna do and I
remember you writing about this and yeah
and call it 20 minutes of Awesome yeah
it's so awesome which is also his tinder
bio
20 minutes might be a stretch but little
things like that are amazing and they're
portable throughout your life wherever
you go geographically workouts are the
same body weight resistance workouts and
but but today I've been able to take
those things and segment them into a
slightly different lifestyle so no
matter where where life takes you and
what you decide to do next is having
little things like that that you can
take and move around your day and that
you can do with whatever equipment you
happen to have at hand nothing is
totally necessary then you're in a
really really good spot I think to
continue to evolve to allow yourself to
evolve without getting stuck and held
back in a way by maybe expensive
equipment that you've purchased or a
reliable Wi-Fi maybe you want to go
someplace where there isn't reliable
Wi-Fi and if one of your rituals and
routines is dependent on that and then
you'll be hamstrung any place that you
want to go where you don't have that
digital umbilical connected all the time
so no matter what equipment you have you
can have 20 minutes of Awesome it's what
Colin is trying to say do you have a
copy of our book everything that remains
okay just you were you at Jess ladies
and gentlemen Jessica Lynne Williams she
is the social media behind the
minimalism and she's pretty awesome yes
we could not do like the reason why our
social media looks awesome is because
jess is a millennial and gets it we
could not do it without her uh yeah I
just wanted to feel like I'm selling
your hobby book suggest we'll give you a
copy of everything that remains but it
does have some stuff in there about
rituals we talked about the 20 minute of
Awesome into some other things in in
there too I think you'll find valuable
one sec so before before we move on if
you're listening to this at home and you
have a comment or tip for anyone who
asks a question today you can give us a
call for 0 6 2 1 9 7 8 3 9 or send a
voice in them all right from your phone
to podcast at the minimalists comm it's
my favorite part of the show at the end
of the show we air a handful of comments
and tips from our listeners which I
borrow and incorporate into my own life
at some point all right Ryan what time
is it is time for our hashtag ask the
minimalists lightning round where yeah
we usually answer questions from social
media but Josh won't be on his phone up
here well why you guys are here so we'll
just we'll take the questions in line
yeah we're on all the socials at the
minimalists we usually answer questions
from there but will what we try to do is
we just try to wrap it up with a really
pithy answer that you could tweet but
because it's on the spot we'll ramble on
a bit and then we'll give you something
tweetable at the end how's that my
question is not about physical items but
instead on the emotional side so how do
you manage your emotions you've had that
you have accumulated throughout your
childhood so an example is my family is
not very close whenever we would do
something as a family my father's
reaction would always be if we have to
or I guess or some similar negative
reaction so every time I would feel such
guilt and feel really bad for my mom and
he he could have totally been just
joking around but I took it as him being
serious so now that I'm in a serious
relationship and my boyfriend does the
same thing I get it I get excited about
trying something new or doing something
I've not done in a long time and his
response is the same way which is
totally fine
that's his personality and I do not want
him to change or not feel comfortable
being himself around me so and we've
talked about it and he explains that
he's joking
but I become overwhelmed with guilt and
sadness every time still so what I'm
asking is how would you go about
removing those childhood emotions that
are getting in the way from growing and
moving forward also I know that we are
different than my parents but how do you
control the worry
and also I'm aware that this is all on
me this is not my mom or dad or
boyfriend's fault
I choose how I respond and how I handle
situations Wow so is he here tonight
okay and I didn't tell him the question
yeah yeah and my first thing it was I
was gonna say is if you've talked to him
about this before and he still reacts
like that it's pretty shitty oven and
but but here's the good news dude you're
totally off hook because you haven't had
this conversation yet you just not off
the hook after tonight and because
because here's the truth you're taking
ownership right you you know there's
like this old cliche like if you were to
you know if I point to Colin like yet
one point one finger is pointing at him
but three are pointing back at me right
and you're actually pointing this back
on yourself and you're taking ownership
of the situation you say how do I get
rid of the guilt but the truth is you
need you need him to be supportive first
and my guess is he doesn't understand
those behaviors it is it we all have our
little tics right and and the way that
we can be supportive of each other is he
needs to understand that about you you
like hey I have this particular
insecurity because guess what we all
have our insecurities right and and he
needs to be able to adjust his feedback
his commentary his interactions with you
accordingly this doesn't mean that he
needs to cobble you unnecessarily that's
not what you're asking for I can tell us
that we were asking for what you're
asking for is a little bit of
understanding and my guess is it's a
serious relationship you said your
boyfriend loves you right and so he
wants to support you and so what what
he's he's gonna need to do is is look
for feedback not criticism because
what what you're seeing this as right
now is criticism you say something is
like I have we have to or on we have to
do it in and the thing is like that's
part of our culture sadly right most of
us live remarkably unremarkable lives
because we've been given this template
this template of lay the and we're
fulfilling this sort of sitcom role of
life sometimes and and we need to step
back from that and so all you're doing
right now is you're asking for support
and I want to applaud you for for taking
ownership of the problem but also for
for asking for help
and I think you need to be willing to
reach out to him whenever something
upsets you and and say hey look like I'm
trying to detach from this emotion and I
can tell you over the years if I have
one superpower in my life its detachment
but it took a long time to get there and
it's not an actual superpower it's like
a building a muscle right because when I
was first approaching minimalism for me
I couldn't detach from anything my
emotions weren't even I certainly
couldn't detach from those I couldn't
even detach from the junk that was
stored in my basement it was holding on
to old magazine collections just in case
I wanted to go back and reference them
someday and I realized like well wait a
minute
I'm holding on to a bunch of stuff that
isn't adding value but guess what a lot
of the emotions that we hold on to don't
add any value to our lives as well oh
that's my pit the answer we could tweet
that Jess I just want to reiterate that
your boyfriend does want to support
that's why he's here tonight so he
actually let's give him a round of
applause your support
so it's it just reiterate what Josh was
saying having that conversation being
clear on where you need the support that
that might need to be refined a little
bit the other thing to here's the
biggest part is you have to support him
as much as possible
you can't just demand support and not
support the other person and I think
that is where I failed mostly in my
relationships like I'm not gonna do
anything until you do something what a
horrible attitude and it ruined a lot of
my relationships so yes ask for ask for
the support and then you got a sport
back to answer the question I guess I
might put the answer for like letting go
of the childhood stuff the way so here's
how I look at my childhood here's my pet
the answer is our childhood it shapes us
but once we leave the home we get to
form how we want our lives to be and
what I mean by that is is when I look at
a lot I got relatives in prison I got
relatives who are hooked on heroin I got
I mean it's it's a mess and I'm not
trying to just land on my dirt dirty
laundry but I will say that it's very
hard for me to to be confident honestly
when I think about all the things that
all the problems that my family has
going on but what I have to tell myself
so I don't make those decisions for them
and yes again they helped shape Who I am
today
and I love Who I am so I do not regret
any of my past or anything if I could go
back and change something to be the same
today of course I would but if I change
something I would not be able to be the
person I am today
so a I appreciate all of those really
crappy memories but the other thing too
is I I really focus on knowing and
practicing that I am not my 25 year old
self I'm not my 15 year old self I'm not
my 5 year old self right now I strive to
be the best 40 year old self that I can
be and I think that's what keeps me
moving forward something I would add to
that too from a slightly different angle
is that a lot of these things that
they don't seem the same as biting your
nails are habits that we have when we
reinforce past habits in ourselves or in
other people when we criticize people
automatically and are not quite sure why
we did it but it's kind of just habitual
and we recognize that later but oh well
the moments already passed so there's
nothing that we can do about it but
noticing is important and recognizing
when you do that to yourself when you
recognize that maybe you're reliving
something that you don't need to relive
because history is not destiny or when
you realize that that maybe you're doing
the same to somebody else and we all
have something that we do that we don't
realize until a certain point in our
life annoys the hell out of other people
or hurts other people and then once we
do realize that maybe we think we can't
do anything about it but picking that
out and recognizing this is a bad habit
and this is something that we can pluck
away it's not something about us it's
like biting your nails biting your nails
doesn't define you and criticizing other
people or criticizing something about
yourself doesn't define you either and
so allowing yourself to to take that
first step and recognize it but then
also deciding that every time you
recognize it in the future in yourself
or in somebody else you'll bring it up
and that might be speaking out loud to
yourself or it might be communicating
incredibly clearly to somebody else in
your life that this is something that
doesn't fit this doesn't fit with who
you are or who they are it's not
something that's part of them it's it's
just biting their nails and it's
something that you can pluck away and be
a more refined version of yourself
rather than it taking away something
that's integral just just one of the one
of the things to point out to you is we
don't get to determine how other people
feel about our actions and that's gonna
go both ways in your relationship for
sure and I've messed up in the past
where like I know I've offended someone
especially yeah a partner of mine and if
I'm in a relationship and I offend you
but I think it's stupid like you
shouldn't be offended by that what's
wrong with you know I don't get to
determine whether or not you're offended
if you're offended you're offended and
so it's it's not it's not I'm sorry if I
hurt your feelings no no I'm sorry that
I did like I didn't mean to and let me
see if I can adjust my behavior going
forward I don't remember a few weeks ago
in
Nashville my partner Rebecca was with me
and we were walking home and I know that
like I was just super tired and I wasn't
giving her the attention that I should
have and like I could tell she felt like
turned off by the interaction we were
having and I just paused and I said hey
look I'm really sorry I can tell that
right now I'm making you feel a
particular way and I realized that is on
me I take ownership and let's talk about
this real quick I'd like to see what I
can do better in the future so that I
make sure this doesn't happen again and
so adjusting my behavior so that I I
realize I can't please everyone as well
but you also don't get to choose whether
or not other person's feelings are hurt
and the same goes for your boyfriend if
he offends you it's not your fault that
you're that you've been offended it's
simply that you were offended by it and
then how do you adjust your interactions
going forward to help fix that thanks
for being here thank you I think there's
a question howdy-hi which I'm Lindsay
I'm from Fort Wayne Indiana thanks for
making the ride so this is the second
time I've guys seen you and since I've
seen you last I've gotten sort of 70% of
my personal belongings and I had you
seen seven hundred percent yes seven
hundred I also have 52 is amazing she
went out stuff she had and then got rid
of it all and I've also changed my
career so congratulations that is
awesome yeah yeah it was not meeting my
needs for short-term or long-term so I
decided to change the issue I'm having
and maybe no set of issues I'm now happy
and I don't really know what to do with
that it sounds so weird I have all of
this time and I'm like my problem is I'm
too happy
well you're welcome next question um
actually I we need to put that like on a
book cover somewhere right yeah after
reading this book I'm too happy I mean
there is actually a problem I mean
there's there's you mean you're not
saying that you're manic right and and
and and so what what you're saying is
like wow I I feel different from how I
have felt in the past and and you're
what you're doing right now is you're
experiencing a new normal but I will
tell you this also it's not it's all not
all gonna be ponies and rainbows right I
mean for those of you who sold the thing
I wrote recently about saying though is
like I have approached a crash recently
and I'm course correcting as a result
and and so there will still be new
problems here's the good news though
that's not bad news it's actually good
news because they're better problems and
you're improving your problems what
we're not we're not doing is we're not
putting oil all over the road to create
no no friction whatsoever you want a
little bit of friction that's how you
get traction that's how you move forward
that's how you grow and so I think where
you're at right now the you you may be
in a spot that you're like wow this is
this is feeling great but in time that's
gonna become comfortable it's gonna go
from a 10 to 8 to a 6 and all of a
sudden you're like okay this is still
pretty good I don't want to give it up
put yourself in a situation of
discomfort and that is the place from
which you will grow that's my pity
answer Jess wherever you are I could
give you a pill right now and it can
make ya good this is that it's a
figurative pill but there are these
pills out there but I could give you a
pill right now and it would make you
feel like however happy all right now
would make you happier okay so here is
let's think about an X weight X Y graph
this is those of you at home he's
yeah think of a graph like a math class
so X yes think of math class think of a
graphing no but think about like X being
time y being the level of happiness so
right now today at this moment I'm gonna
put you here and then tomorrow that pill
is gonna keep you there and it's gonna
keep you there the third day and so on
and so forth what happens is that
because of our silly human brains this
becomes normal and that becomes the new
X and I'm saying this because we have
this really just crazy like saying in
the Western world of you know if you if
you find something you love to do you
don't you know you don't ever work a day
in your life yeah and it's [ __ ] like
it really is now I'm not saying there's
probably someone here or if not there's
someone in the world many people in the
world who can say that there is always
going to be an exception to a rule those
are exceptions to the rule by and large
that is I feel like that is not a
reasonable expectation for every single
one of us sitting in this room so so it
for me
happiness is not the point anymore
happiness is a beautiful byproduct of
what I do trying to live a meaningful
life and and that is really what I focus
on so if I had to guess where you're at
right now I'd say that you're bored
you're happy but you're bored and and
that's okay but the way you got happy is
you took so much action to get there and
you had a goal and you got there any
declared decluttered and great and now
you have made room for something else
you do have to figure out what that
something else is there is something
else there but you've got to be able to
determine what that is if I had to give
like a the pithy answer would be sitting
around and doing nothing while you're
happy will always lead to you being
unhappy does that make sense there with
the board so I just don't know where the
direction is right so so so this is this
is what I'm what I would encourage you
to do is just I'm tempted to just ask
you right now like what is
just name one thing right now that
you've that you really want to put time
into that you literally have put no time
into over the last six months service
okay perfect
start there and if there's if you got
five things and you feel really strongly
about five things that's great you've
got a lot of interest that is awesome
because a lot of people don't start with
that many interest write them up on
little slips of paper put them in a hat
and pick one out and start there but but
it's saying that you said community
service right off the bat let tells me
that's probably the one thing you need
to start with so I would start with some
community service now don't feel like
you got to put in forty hours a week a
community service just start with an
hour what do you have a week even if
it's a half hour like I know when Josh
and I when we go to the soup kitchen and
we put an hour in like they're so
thankful if we put six hours in there
just this thankful so don't don't
overcommit start small and then you know
kind of layer up as you go but but yes
you again sitting around while you're
happy will always lead to you being
unhappy the a mental model that helps me
with this because I dealt with the same
thing particularly back in 2009 when I
went from working like a hundred hours a
week running a branding studio in LA to
suddenly having essentially 24 hours a
day to spend doing whatever which is a
really crazy shift and and there are
moments where you're like I am wasting
my time I once had goals I had purpose I
had stuff to do but the thing that I
tend to think about or I think in terms
of now is that every time you free up
time energy or resources and that's kind
of what minimalism and intentionality in
general is all about it's almost like
you're undergoing some kind of
industrial revolution and suddenly you
have access to this new power source
it's steam power or electricity and if
you think of this little Hamlet's on the
hill and they've got no electricity and
suddenly it's electrified they have a
lot of potential to do a bunch of stuff
but the infrastructure is not there yet
and so what you want to do is go through
and build the infrastructure and make
sure you can utilize this new torque
that you have access to and recognize
that you you are empowered in a new way
to spend all of this time energy and
resources on new things but you want to
do it in a way that doesn't blow
anything up you don't want to set that
Hamlet ablaze you want to make sure that
your building slowly but surely
something that's more power
and and hopefully in a lot of ways
better than what was there before a more
refined version of what was there before
so that's a mental model that helps me
as I increment in these different ways
every time you get a little bit
healthier or you get a little bit more
time or you feel like you developed a
new skill or learned something new
that's a new mini Industrial Revolution
and you get to choose how to spend it
but you want to make sure that like they
were saying that you do it well you
don't burn yourself out and you make
sure that you think very carefully about
what you spend it on thank you very much
thank you
Congrats on everything keep up the great
work real quick we like I said we just
landed and ended up here so we won't
have time for an added value segment
because nothing has added value to our
lives in Milwaukee yet because that's
all of you we have we haven't been
outside of the the walls here but you
guys heard it uber really helped me get
here today but I do want to say this
venue is one of my favorites and I'll
tell you the reason why is when we got
here they're like oh yeah we have a
coffee shop and a barista downstairs I'm
like that's pretty cool then you at the
coffee shop know like they set up just
for their performers they have a coffee
shop that's functioning downstairs and
it's collected colectivo coffee which is
my favorite spot in Milwaukee so if
you're listening to this at home and you
want some great coffee the next time you
come to Milwaukee check out colectivo
Sean do we have time for one more bonus
question okay get a thumbs up back there
yeah okay we got time for one more
question I apologize other folks who
were in line we'll do a quick bonus
question here
all right you a quick interruption if
you want to listen to our bonus episode
this week as well as all of our past
bonus episodes head on over to the
minimalists dot-com and click donate at
the top of our website each week we
publish the minimalists private podcast
exclusively for our patreon supporters
this private podcast shows up in your
normal podcast feed like Apple podcasts
overcast Google Play or whatever podcast
app you use and it shows up right next
to our normal weekly podcast you know
the one you're listening to right now
and being a patreon supporter also gets
you first access to the best
it's to all of our live events as well
as access to our monthly private live
stream video which is called ask the
minimalists anything it's worth noting
that none of this money goes to me or to
Ryan instead we're using your
contributions to build a new podcast in
film studio in Los Angeles so that we
can create more meaningful audio and
video creations if you already support
this podcast thank you I know that $2
often doesn't sound like a lot of money
I mean it's less than a cup of coffee
but it is your support that keeps this
podcast 100% advertisement free because
advertisements suck and if we can just
get two percent of our audience to
support this show then we'll have enough
funds to produce some amazing new
creations your support is truly
appreciated all right Joe back to the
regular show before we wrap it up I just
want to acknowledge a few folks we've
been on tour all year like I said we're
doing 50 cities in one year this is
wrapping up all of North America and on
the road with us in every single city we
have Jessica Lynn Williams and podcast
Sean he's always hiding back there in
the shadows
[Applause]
and speaking of added value that added
value they've added immense value to our
lives they spend time away from their
friends and family and sean has 17 kids
I think no he does have three kids
though and and he's often on the road
with us for long stretches of time and
we're grateful for that and Jess she
leaves her husband for sometimes a week
at a time to be on the road with us and
really grateful he decided to spend your
time with us saying thank you so much
and oh I'm my partner Rebecca she went
to school in Madison and she told me to
end the tour by saying by saying go
badgers
last person tonight I want to thank is
you I know you spent some money to get
in here we're really grateful for that
allows us to pay for all the staff and
security and even have a bed to sleep in
tonight and definitely grateful for that
but you also gave up your two most
precious resources you gave up your time
and your attention and we are really
grateful for that if you all live here
tonight with just one message we hope
it's this love people and use things
because the opposite never works thank
you thank you so much Milwaukee you're
awesome thank you so much hello i'm ladi
from brazil and this is for the lady who
asked about minimizing beauty products
on episode 116 resonate first don't let
social media like Pinterest and
Instagram compel you to consume it's
easy to mistake inspiration with
comparison to me minimalist beauty could
be about enhancing what you have instead
of spending time and money trying to
change it I found freedom in embracing
my natural hair texture in color
I found a hairdresser who knew how to
properly cut my hair type then minimize
the time and money spent try to change
it about makeup you can minimize the
amount of stuff by only multi-purpose
tools like a Beauty Blender that
replaced all skin and concealer brushes
for me get rid of repeated items and
throw away expired makeup as you can
grow bacteria and cause breakouts and
don't feel bad if you paid a lot for
something in it to toss it if buying an
item made you happy it already served
its purpose hi this is Roger from Bonita
Caribbean Netherlands I was listening to
your podcast about happier and one of
the questions was that I know what my
future happiness should be but how can I
live more in a moment
and happiness for me isn't much like it
can be small things like happiness
roomies hugging my dog's happiness for
me is watching the rainbow happiness for
me is driving my car to work enjoying
listening to the radio so the simple
things can bring you happiness you don't
have to focus on all the big things
that will be my advice and the future is
the future is far away so try and enjoy
what you have now even though not
everything is what you want now what do
you have hello it is kit like a kit kat
bar calling from Toronto Ontario I just
listened to your podcast about happiness
and I know you just posted your next
podcast resonate but I did want to
comment on meditation as I'm an
individual who is very frustrated at the
beginning of their meditation journey
since I'm somebody who has a monkey mind
and the traditional idea of meditation
the sitting closing your eyes and
clearing your mind just didn't resonate
with me so I go for each and I found out
that meditation is actually more about
being in the present moment and once I
was able to wrap my mind around this
concept it was a lot easier for me to
actually have a mindful practice in
everyday life whether I'm doing the
dishes or the laundry any mundane tasks
can be meditation it's as long as you're
being mindful and you're being present
and you're being aware so keep in mind
that individuals who are maybe
frustrated with the traditional idea of
meditation you can actually meditate
when you're dancing when you're going to
the gym a walk in the park or even when
you're watching TV it can really be
anything that you enjoy as long as
you're present and in the moment so I
just thought that would be a helpful tip
for anybody else who is frustrated out
there and to just keep that all in mind
[Music]
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing that's just feeding
your greed oh I bet that you'll be fine
without it
[Music]
every little thing that you got a hand
every little thing that you guys you
gotta reach for and you got a grand oh I
bet that you'll be fine without your
[Music]
team
[Music]
you